bien vamos a hacer un ejercicio de la
sección realizando traslaciones y nos
dicen utiliza la herramienta trasladar
para encontrar la imagen del triángulo w
y en este que está aquí doble 1 y n este
es el triángulo tras una traslación de 6
unidades el 6 es positivo 6 unidades en
la dirección x y menos 3 unidades
esta vez el menos 3 pues es negativo en
la dirección de iu bien lo que voy a
hacer es activar el botón que dice
trasladar este que está aquí
y después lo que voy a hacer es me dicen
que tenemos que trasladar 6 unidades en
la dirección x ver voy a hacer eso
primero entonces tomo este punto podría
tomar cualquiera pero voy a empezar con
este que está aquí y ahora vamos 1 2 3 4
5 6 muy bien entonces ya hice esta
primer parte
es trasladar seis unidades en la
dirección x ahora tengo que ir menos
tres unidades en la dirección y y para
hacer eso ahora lo que voy a hacer es
tomar el mismo punto y tengo que ir
hacia abajo muy bien entonces menos 1 -
2 - 3 perfecto ahora yo empecé
trabajando con este punto pero podría
haberlo hecho con cualquiera observó que
este punto es la imagen del punto n como
de hecho todo este triángulo es la
imagen del triángulo w
n y así con cada uno de los otros puntos
que observemos otro de los puntos por
ejemplo el punto que se encuentra aquí
éste tiene una coordenada horizontal o x
igual a 1.5 que es lo que aquí se
observa el que resultó de la
transformación
seis unidades a la derecha de él veamos
este punto que es el que corresponde
está en la coordenada 7.5 en el eje x
muy bien y lo mismo pasa con su
coordenada n
el punto inicial o del triángulo
original estaba en la coordenada 6 en el
eje vertical y lo trasladamos - 3
unidades en esa dirección así que ahora
se encuentra en el 3 vertical lo mismo
ocurrió con todos los puntos de este
triángulo bien comprobemos nuestra
respuesta
muy bien